LEAVE ME ALONE D:
OH, MY GOD ;O;
Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica
Now, unfortunately, or fortunately, depending on what you think,
Every thing in the game has changed.
And I don't just mean like I said in the last episode,
Even the way I have to approach the game has now changed.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WANTS TO KILL ME DEAD!
That is simply a FACT!
EVERYTHING now wants to murder me, break my ship that I built for so much (stutters) f un and stuff,,
(more serious) And they want to cavitate me until I explode.
And I know I'm not using the word cavitate correctly!
Because SOMEONE here by the name of, uh, Aiden Patman Clark has corrected me.
So Aiden says, "Mark, cavitation is a real scientific term when a submarine propeller's turning extremely fast
in a very high pressure making the water around it boil, which creates loud noises and visible steam.
Combat submarines have a stealth mode in which the propeller turns slowly to prevent cavitation.
Just a word from an ex-naval submarine pilot."
So,  they actually know what cavitating means, and now we know that as well.
Also, Steven Fox who said, (singing) "F is for friends that you don't even have!
U is for you are lonely~!
N is for no child support down her-" oh wait? (weirded out) "down here.. in the deep blue sea!"
Ah, And then Hunter Shiflett who said "Mark the blueprint for the decoy that you can put in the cyclops is
in Life Pod 4. Life Pod 4 is by the Aurora."
Which means that we're gunna have to go over there,
And then there's NoHorse who said, "Hey Mark, just a theory but the base MIGHT have sprung a leak
when you RAMMED A SUBMARINE INTO IT!!!"
(defensively) Which I don't remember doing!
I don't think that was my fault! It was the weird bug where I'd go in there and, uh, it'd suddenly
joltz to the left.
So not my fault! But we've got a mission to do. We've now got the jet upgrade,
In this badboy. Which means,
oooo. OOHH ! (stutters) that is, that is quite a bit more responsive, I do like that! A lot!
Why couldn't it been like that base line level -- WWhaaYY oh.... Did I just ram into my god damn..
Okay, there we go (looks uncomfortable).
[Welcome aboard, Captain] I better not have sprung a leak in here!
You better not have done that to me! (Mark, if there's a leak, it might be your fault ;) )
..Alright, fine then! I'm gonna trust you on this one... But! Now that I've been playing the game
and now that this, actually, this release got, uh, released to the FULL VERSION at - for the public,
I'm still in the developer version of the game, but, the full version has been released.
And there are a few other things that I need to be mindful of.
There are upgrades to the cyclops that I can make. And these are important because they help,
with things like ME BEING ATTACKED BY MONSTERS!
There's a shield upgrade, there is a, uh, obviously the decoy thing, there is also..
A mapping, scanning type thing that you can do that will help you in terms of just being able to know
the environment that you're around so that I don't slam into them with my hull and break everything in my ship.
But I've got a mission, because with this new update there have been (grimaces in fear)
[Warning: Ahead slow] Ahead slow... am I still cavitating? Gosh, I hope not..
I really hope not... (ahem) So, with this update I've got a few new avenues to go.
There are the alien caches that are now available in the Crag Field, and the Mushroom Forest.
So I could go to either of those and pick some new Ion Crystals,  which I do desperately need.
And also! I need to go now to every single Life Pod. Because not only in Life Pod 4 is there the decoy tube,
but every single on of those Life Pods has an informational ThingamaBobber™.
Which means that I need-- OH it is night....(fear). Which means that I need to..
Go Do That Thing.
Ooh Hi, Forest. I keep forgetting that I'm directly below the island every time I go there.
Which is awfully nice, I suppose (mutters) for some comfort.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go to the Crag Field because that is actually the one that is closest to me.
And I don't BELIEEVe... I don't BELIEEVE there's too many horrible monstrosities down there?
[Markiplier begins to look increasingly uncomfortable]
And I know I'm cavitating right now, but I just need to get there quickly, because as soon as something pops up on
my radar that's gonna be super evil I'm gonna... [stutters] Imunna go to - go to super silent -
But! - The thing that's changed the most about this game and what I was saying about
how I need to approach it differently is -
*dramatic pause*
I'M NOT SAFE ANYMORE!
(that voice crack tho)
[sounding almost happy about it] THERE IS NO SAFE.
*pouts in a terrified manner*
I'm ALONE in the OCEAN, desperately clinging on to something and before,
I had a cyclops that was indestructible!
And now if I go down into the firey pits of Hell where I wanted to build a base...
Σ(ﾟдﾟ;)∑
That ain't gonna work too well for me, I just pissed my pants as you can see!
(nice rhyme)
Eh....
It's all just going to shit!
Very quickly! But...
We've got a whole new world to explore and a new way to do it,
so let's try to get these Alien caches while we can and then hopefully
build a base down deep in the depths, which is still something that I wanna do
and still my pr - Oooooohhhhh ...
[slows speed to hide from the ocean]
I see - aaaAAaaaah, it's coming right for me!
You don't know where I am - SILENT.
Eugh....
Ah...
Ahhh.........
AHhhh......
What's in the water that's so spooky *raises intensity* WHAT'S in the WATER THAT'S so SPOOKY.
(ﾟΩﾟ;)
I don't see anything in the wa-aaaaaater
Oh god.
Oh GOD!
I'm sorrounded!
Oh god.
Eugh...
What is that?
[slabbing words together] ..'s jut a fish..
Okay...
*Markiplier makes a sound of relieved disgust*
Ey - wh - Ehwhy is it right on top of me??
Where is it?!
Okay, bye...
*shudders*
Eugh...
...no
Why would you do this to me...?
Why would you DO THIS to me...?
I THINK I'M NEAR THE CRAG FIELDS  -
BUT IT'S GODDAMN NIGHT TIME -
I'm gonna go sleep in my bed!
Imunna sleep until the night goes away!
And I'm gonna *sobs* live my life again!
WHY!?
Why do they have to made these chaanges?
Ohhh...
Why did they do it...
Okay, at least I can see now...
Oh, mysteriously the monsters are still there
(holy SHIT that shoulder looks broken)
I gotta actually look at the camera system to try to find where I am
I think...
Is this the Crag Field?
This looks like it might be some sort of
*BANG BANG CRASH BANG BANG*
aaAAAAAAAYY, WHAT DID I HIT
Oh, Goddamnit, I'm SILENTLY running!
WHY!!???
(the fish don't care about your feelings, Mark)
I'M freakin' SILENT, brah!
Okay, they can't seem to hurt me, but that's okay
Oh my Gad, I'm SURROUNDED D:
ゝ(◎◇◎;)
OH my GAD, that's TERRIFYING
There's so many of 'em! ((ﾟДﾟ;)
*beached whale noise*
*mating call*
Oh God...
Well, I'm, I'm definitel - eeeeeuuugh
STOP!! D:
I'M SILENT!!
At least you can't hurt me, so that's good.
So, those don't seem tough enough to be able to do some damage,
but that's weird considering I THOUGHT-
*Mark dazed in fright*
Cyclops: External hull damage detected!
OH NOW we have external hull damage! GReaT!
It wasn't there beFORrre
Cyclops: Ahead slow
Agh... Fhuck
*Crash* AGH
[Cyclops: Warning! Creature attack!] GODDAMNIT
No joke creature attack!
Go to silent!
Cyclops:..Silent Running.
Eugh
*scared/stunned* I gotta go out there and repair it
I gotta go repair it!
OWAH ;O;
idon'twanna ;-;
I don't wanna..
Okay, here we go
Gotta find th- th- Oh my, god.
Stohp... Just leave it alone...
It's not worth it, man! It's not worth it! :(
LEAVE ME ALONE D:
OH MY GOD ;O;
WHAY???
WHYY??
*long ass pause*
;_; ... Okay...
*extremely shookethed Mark* Okay, I'm gonna pick this up while I'm out here
I guess
(not sure what he says here but..) Yesh!
*back to normal Mark* OKayy! So, somewhere in here
SUMWhere
in here
*suspense pause*
there is...
an Alien cache
and I've gotta find it!
Cuz there's Alien data in there that I'm gonna need
Cyclops:.. Captain. All systems online.
*creepy Mark* IS IT
is that true?
*normal Mark* Are all systems online? You sure about that?
or are all systems
ABOUT TO BLOW?!
Let me drink my piss ;-;
that's the only thing that can bring me COMfort
in these trying times :(
*realizes* I thought I was on silent running.
Can you please go to silent?
No, don't sound the horn!
DON't sound th-
YOU WANNA SOUND THE HORN
I AIN'T GONNA SOUND GODDAMN HORN
You frickin-
DOoooNT DO THAT
*Crash*
WHY?
Cyclops: Creature Attack! Silent Running
Okay...!
Silent running.
Get off.
We're on silent!
There's damage? I'll get it in a second!
You s-
STOPPPP
*long pause but lmaoooo, look at his fayyce*
My, god!
It's lethal here!
It's frick-dicken lethal
They wanna kill me!
THEY WANNA KILL BIG-BOX-BERRY
I won't let them do that! D:<
Although, I don't know if I'll have a choice in the matter
(that's not the spirit ;-; )
Alrighty, you know what? I'm just gonna go
OAUT (out)
and I'm gonna beat the SHIT OUT OF 'EM
because THEY wanna pick a fight,
they're gonna get a fight
HEY, YOU WANNA FIGHT?
HUH?
Oh, oH, OH
you wanna fiGHT BRAH (calm down Mark)
oh you better ruunn BITCH
oh, you better ruUUN BITCH
OH you better RUUN BITCH
OH you bETTER RUUNN
oh yea- oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah? Oh yeah? Oh yeah??? OH YEAH? OH YEA-
you didn't think you were going to pick a fight with
ME (the brave little markimoo)
that's right.
THAT'S RIGHT
THAS ROIGHT
thas roigh
you mes with Big Box Barry you get the-
(Mark snake dance)
the HORN TEETH
the Markimoo's *voicecrack* HORN TEETH
patent pending...
*rawr*
HEY
hey
hey you want round two, baby? (Mark being confident)
You the same one? (Shark-ist, MARK)
huh?!?
OooOOH got you in my Trap!
You've activated my trap card!
*cue intense anime music*
are you dead? 0_o
you seem to be still be twitching.. (bestest grammar mark)
this feels-
that now- this feels wrong...
originally I was gloating but now it just feels like
Feels like I'm being cruel here... (getting this now Mark?)
(kill me, end my pain)
You-
Ok, you STAY DOWN
hope you learned you lesson!
(SO MUCH PAIN)
(Punch of fear)
Alright...Ok then.
Noooo! You wanna fight bruh? I'll (stutters) I'll take you ALL on!
I'll take every last one of you on.
HLAAAH! (Hyaah? Hlaagth?)
Huh? You wanna go? Ooooh...AAANND
Cycle back, cycle back, circle back
I dare you, I dare ye, Oh What?
You can't escape! (Miss of epic proportions) Oh...
Y-y-you CAN'T ESCAPE
MEEEEEEEEE BABY!~
Whoa, that—that—that
boomerang got in the way and I shouldn't have done that.
HYAAAAH!
Where you taking me? Where you carrying me?
Where—Where are you running off to?
Where do you think you can run?
YOU THINK YOU CAN RUN? YOU THINK YOU CAN RUN?!
You think you can just...RUN?!
Oh, that's right!
Wait are you dead or not? I can't tell.
(achievement unlock: overkill)
PLLLLBTTTHTBPLTHHHHHHHHH! That's a lot of blood.
Ok, you're dead. Yeah he's dead. Ok, he's dead.
Alright! Took care of another one!
Maan! He carried me far away!
Wa—HEYAYAYAYAYAYAYAYAYAAAYAAAY
(I SAID HEY)
Huh?
(WHAT'S GOING ON)
What?
You avenging your bro?
I'll take another one of y' on, yeah, three's the charm here!
Sending the three musketeers down to the GRRAAAAVVE!
The briny depth!
The Johnny Depp-th
Ok, you dead?
Alright he's dead.
Man, they - they all must've been dead a long time ago and I was just
kept whaling on them like that—oh god.
(much grammar)
Oh that's weird.
Hllegth. (disgust)
Sorry!
I mean, I'm not sorry at all, in any capacity, but still
SSOORRRRYY!
So what are we looking for here—we're looking for
some sort of a ThingamaBobber™.
Which means—ooohhh.
SORRY!
n. ThingamaBobber™:
Something, anything of interest whose name you can't remember for the life of you.
That was my bad!
Which means that I
need to either go exploring or look up where it is.
So I'm gonna do the latter because I know it's gonna...
take me a while, so I'll be righto-backo!
(right tobacco?)
Alright, so apparently I'm close by...
It's just a little over this way!
SCHHHHH—WOOPDEY!
Sweet jet upgrade bruh!
Oh, is it down there?
Please tell me there's nothing big down there.
Am I in the right direction here? Ooo~
Alrighty then!
Yeah! I think I'll—EYYYYYYYY
NANANANANANA None of that, none of that.
(BATMAN)
NYOLGHNE OF THLAAAT! (garbled "None of that")
NYOLGHNE OF THLAAAT NOOW!
None of that.
Let's not have ANY OF THAT!
And I'll just be on my way, and you have a lovely day!
And UHH...Uhhh...Uhhh eat some—a...eat some fire! (Best insult ever ^^)
eat—eat fire. literally eat fire.
(mark, what does water do to fire?)
Oooh, rocketing into the winner circle~
Where the hell am I?
Is this the winner circle?
ooo~OOOOHH! Hello
OOHALRIGHTY THEN! I'VE STUMBLED ACROSS IT!
Alrighty then!
Hey... Hey! hEY!HEYHEYHEYHEY!
(Markiplier becomes a Chihuahua)
You wanna fight? You'll see how this ended for all you're FRIENDS!
BAADDLLY!
Ok, you, uh, you run off, you run off. You-you were smart, you w're smart, you stopped the fight soon.
ok.
So I gotta go in there—Oh no.
Hooh! (relief) I thought I was stuck there for a second!
Okay, so I gotta go there under my own two feet.
Hyuh! (Jump sound).
Wait.
I literally went in under my own two feet; I did not expect there to be oxygen in here!
Huh! Speckled Rattler?
d-gross!
Ok, I don't know if I'm gonna need to—
Oooh! Hey! How'd you get in here?
OOOWWWW!
Jeezums, you douche!
Whoooaa!
Ok, this is not what I was expecting.
Ooo.
I don't know.
These pink caps good for anything?
naah, they're just samples.
OOOOOO!
What's down there?
Death? I hope it's death!
(lowkey same)
W'll, I know there's another way to go, but there's
's a way to go down here AY!YIEYIEYIEYieyie
Jeez...
Alright, looks like nothing!
So far, anyway. Yeah, it's just another way down here.
So... why did they build a cave? Or wh -
Did they excavate this or is this naturally ocurring?
That is the question—Oh my god!
ho-kay?
Well it's beautiful, and I'm glad that there's this nice convenient path here, but at the same time...
WWWHHAAAATTT THE HEELLL? OOOOooooh
OOOHHHHH!
oh my god! It's another gateway!
OH!
Well no ion crystal for me, but even so!
There's a gateway here!
Now I know this probably doesn't work, much like the other one, but(t)...
at least I know that this one is in the Crag field, which is gonna be good
Because that means if I ever do get down below, and there is the gateway down there, maybe...
JUST MAYBE I'd be able to traverse between the two of 'em.
And I'd be able to get something out of that. But I'm gonna go down there!
Just in case, 'cause I wanna be...thorough!
I wanna make sure-o. M'kay. Alright.
I think that was the end of it! I didn't see any datapads or anything there, but.
That's good to know that this is down here because the Crag field is one of the most resource rich areas
In this game, which means that if I need to make resource runs,
This is where I'munna be going.
Hwup! (jump noise)
(nice acrobatics there)
So let's see if I can remember this area. WHOOP!
SPPOOOOOPP! Aww, this jet upgrade is the BEST~!
whoooOOOOOOOooo! OH MY GOD
IT'S AMAZING!
Why's it gotta be night again?
(that's how day/night cycles work, Mark)
I thought it was just day!
IT WAS JUST DAY!
Alright. So my next stop is
*UNGODLY SCREECH*
Fucking hell, you guys are so scary!
Why are you so scary?
Stop being scary!
This is supposed to be a game about fun and exploration, and love and hugs!
AAAAAaaaaah.
Hugged Big Box Barry a little too hard there, meant to go in the god— there it is.
It's a little too far forward, I chest-bumped him.
Yeah,you know, for fun and happiness, because we're friends and we loooove each other.
Awww fuck, there's damage, OKAY I'll take care of that later.
Other than that we gotta get going here, so.
Let's go silent running, actually
I don't think they can keep up with me when I'm
I think that was just an impact, but I'm gonna say he
died on that one because he disappeared off my radar.
Alrighty then, BREACH BREACH BREACH!
Where is the goddamn ship?
Ohhhh! This ain't good.
How did I get dam—hull—damaged?
How did I get hull dablage?
An' why was I pointed in the wrong direction?
Alright, it's fine, whatever.
Oh no. Oh no, oh no. I'munna save.
Because I'm gonna be skirting right past
[worried intake of breath]
LEVIATHAN TERRITORY!!!!!!
What is that?
（｀〇Д〇）
*BWEEWO BWEEWO BWEEWO*
Huh?
Was that a leviath-ANNE?!
◑.◑
（ΟΔΟ；；）
( ⚆ _ ⚆ )
[Warning: Cavitating]
(`･/д＼･)
OKAAAY!
[distressed whale noise]
I think I remember where lifepod 4 was, but
I'VE GOT A BAD FEELING ABOUT THIS.
uwuuuUUUUUUGGGHHH What are you?!
AAAH! What are you?!
I don't know what any of you are.
None of you better be a leviathanne!
And I know it's really stupid of me to be going this fast but -
Ughh
uh. Oh, hey buddy!
What are you doing on the surface?
(Reefback X Big Box Barry 4 life)
Fuck, sorry!
Jeezums.
The one thing I do like is the speed. The speed is nice, I li, I like going this fast. This fast is good, but.
The cavitating, yeah that's bad but.
even so.
Can't deny, the speed is nice, a welcome change from the previous incarnation of this.
Oh, boy.
uwOah, Is that what cavitating is? That looks like cavitATing!
I'm AWARE! I also gotta not navigate myself into the shallows and beach this thing
Because that's gonna do an unbelievable amount of damage and not be good for me generally all over.
A-PLBTH. a-A-PLABTH. AAH-PLBLTH.
Okay.
So, I think I know where the lifepod is, and I think I'm gonna be getting away from anything that's gonna be hurting me.
I don't know how lethal the sand sharks are in comparison to everything else in this game, but.
I have a funny feeling I'm gonna be ok.
I'm gonna be ok, and everything is gonna be fine.
I just pissed my pants, but that doesn't mean that things are not gonna be ok.
I - I li - I like this, though. I will admit, I like this.
I have not felt this terrified in Subnautica for a while because the threat is real.
And that's something horror games, you know, they're either good or very bad at.
Is maintaining the threat.
An -
Something about the ocean, and now the fact that everything can kill me extremely dead, and will pursue me!
If I come after them.
Just makes the threat all that much more real.
I know.
But it seems like we're here.
Back by the Aurora. And the sun is breaking. So I'm gonna stop for just a second
It's not the end of the episode just yet, but I'm gonna stop.
Right here, and fix all the damlage, because there's a lot of it.
Blip Blap Bloop Blep.
And then, we're gonna have a good time. Ooh boy.
But no, I-I-I-I love this.
Like, it's back to true form of what it once was, and
and that's a beautiful thing, like
I understand why the developers did it, because it NEEDED to be that way.
The-the Cyclops couldn't be this permanently,
you know, established fixture that was unbreakable considering,
The fricking sea dragon was able to, bash
into a precursor base with just its frickin Head Honker™.
Which usually means
There's a lot of death going on; I-I don't recall this being here but I'm gonna take these just in case I need 'em.
huh, power cell? Hell yeah, I'll take that.
If I can get more ion crystals, I'll be able to do better on that one, an-
Wow, this thing is skippedy-doo-da!
OH MY GOD! JEFFREY, BILLY, SAMWISE, AND MARSHALL!
OH MY- woah-OH MY GOD!
It's been so long!
Too bad I don't need really you anymore
[rejected]
I don't know how to make those upgrades, the ones I was talking to you about, like the shield upgrade and whatnot.
I checked—
I checked the uh - the upgrade module place, and that didn't seem to have any answers for me, and then I checked the-uh
I checked the-uh
The-um locker on the-uh-
[yes, much locker]
or err the crafting machine inside my Cyclops, and that didn't seem to have the answer for me.
So I don't know where it is, and oh my god this is so fast.
Propulsion cannon, I've already got that.
I'm just grabbing up some supplies while I can because I'll always need them.
You never know when you need them, and might as well get them now, but...
Okay, I think that's all I need for here, so I'm gonna carry on
to life-pod 4, which if I'm not mistaken, it was the one floating upside-down.
Uhh.
Just to the left of here.
I don't have the-the beacon on me, but we'll see what happens.
Just dive a little bit under, whoo that's a close cut there!
So around here somewhere, and I've gotta be careful because there are leviathans in this area.
And they will probably mess me up...to no end.
If I let them—Ah! There it is! It's still there!
It's still upside down! That's so sad! Why is that sad? It's a little sad, I don't know.
Alright then, I'm coming for you!
I guess!
Huhhhhhh.
So apparently there's the decoy blueprint
(not really)
In this one. And I'm guessing, If I had to guess,
Oh boy, can I climb in there? No?
Alrighty then, how do I get in you again? Oh, the GIANT GAPING HOLE. That-that makes sense.
oh, okay. So I'm guessing
That the upgrades that this gives to me
(not really)
Means, that they'll all come, like the-the shield upgrade, and like the-the decoy, and the other upgrade
that belong to the Cyclops now, will all come from these blueprints,
And so if I got that, then that means that I should have that, right?
(not really)
Right??? A DECOY MAYBE?
How do I do that? I don't seem to have anything...
Someone told me that this was gonna be where the decoy was
And I don't see no decoy here, so maybe you could shut your trap and...
Where the hell?
It didn't do anything once I got that! Like, I got the data downloaded, and it didn't do anything!
OOOOOOHHHHHHHH!
OOHH!
Well, I guess it would've shown up here, but maybe I need to get more of them!
Maybe?
I have no idea...
Or maybe it's because I'm still in the experimental build but if that's the case, I just got the thing and now I won't get it anymore.
But maybe, I could probably figure out a way to reset that... but just for right now.
Yeah, I guess that didn't quite work, I don't know why.
But either way, that's all the time I got for this episode,
It's been a terrifying adventure, and it's only gonna get worse, because I'm about to go into the Koosh zone again, and...
There's a lot of LEVIATHANS over there!
[nervous gulp]
(/-(ｴ)-＼)
And that's bad, and I'm not looking forward to it, but that's where I'm going.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
Let me know what you think in the comments down below,
And as always, I will see you, in the next video!
Buh-Bye!
[Outro Music]